barras et bailly l'epa police justice
comme on veut nous le faire croire il
est gauche droite
il est une vision de la gauche
judiciaire comme une vision de la droite
judiciaire à partir du moment où vous
avez des gardes des sceaux ou à sa tante
de personnes dans l'entourage du garde
des sceaux qui estime que en fait la
sanction c'est pas bien la prison c'est
pas bien vous ne pouvez pas vous étonner
que ce type de manifestation
donc n'opposons pas la justice et la
police qui est une erreur mais c'est une
vision politique de la justice et
notamment qu'à la gauche judiciaire pour
qui en gros la sanction c'est pas bien
il faut pas des gens ayant pris un an go
on peut considérer que depuis madame
taubira en passant par madame belloubet
et jusqu'à eric dupond-moretti on a
exactement la même politique au mr
justice et le en même temps en terme de
sécurité
chère à notre président ne fonctionne
pas la sécurité c'est d'abord et avant
tout un problème de l'état à preuve
régaliens la région n'est là que pour
aider concrètement le budget sécurité en
six ans elle était multipliée par 5 donc
j'ai eu la possibilité de faire à se
rendre de choses on a voté par exemple
bouclier de sécurité nous a permis
d'aider les mères le maire et de ses
épaules et judiciaire les maires peuvent
avoir de la vidéoprotection pas voir des
polices municipales
par exemple nous avons aidé trois cent
trente deux communes à s'équiper en vue
de produire à travers des subventions
publiques et même des subventions
absolument de la même façon on a aidé
plus de 300 communes à équiper des
polices municipales et même l'état a
construit on va rénover des débits c'est
ça mais vous êtes dans l'aide alors si
c'est pour ça que bordés là par exemple
le dit du rassemblement national que
valérie pécresse a une politique molle
sur le sujet la palme du cynisme
pourrait peut-être revenir au
rassemblement national puisque monsieur
bardella et son groupe siège au conseil
régional avec moi depuis maintenant six
ans jamais jamais ils n'ont voté
favorablement à aucune des dispositions
j'ai proposé et j'en veux tu es soit
contre soit ils se sont abstenus sur le
thème suivant peut-être qu'il
considérait que vous n'alliez pas trop
loin sur le thème soit c'était sur le
thème se met en scène
la sécurité est exclusivement un
problème de l'état la région n'a pas à
s'en mêler
alors c'est quand même d'un immense
cynisme de voir qu'aujourd'hui le thème
majeur de la sécurité de rations
nationale c'est la sécurité sur lequel
ils n'ont absolument rien fait ils ont
toujours voté ou contre ou se sont
abstenus
pendant les six ans les six dernières
années